foreign
Janet is in Boise Idaho hi Janet welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey Ken and Dave it's a pleasure ours
too how can we help
yeah so I'm calling today just to see
how we as we as me and my husband can
get ahead of our bills it seems like
every single month we pay our bills
three weeks after the due date and then
a week later they're due again
so we've tried you know budgeting and
just trying to get ahead and we just
can't seem to get that curve um so we're
just calling to see what tips and tricks
you could provide for us
what's your household income
it's about 75 000 growth
how much debt do you have not counting
your house
39 000 on what
on student loans is twenty four thousand
five thousand in credit cards and a 9
000 or 10 000 on the RV travel trailer
on a trailer okay and you make 75k a
year
that's right between the both of us okay
all right
um
all right so where do you think your
money's going
well I know that it was going to a lot
of eating out um I actually just got my
husband on board about two months ago to
do like the baby steps I've been doing
it probably by myself for like a whole
year
um ever since and it seems like actually
we've been on this momentum of just
being behind for like the last year and
we're just sick of it I'm tired of
handling it so I have him stepping in
all the finances
as well as just really you know being
careful with where our money is going
and so you know I've tried for the last
two months these have just been you know
paying every single week um can we get
paid every week so that's kind of so if
I sat down with you and your husband
with a yellow pad at the kitchen table
and I said okay this is what you have
coming in this week let's let's map out
where every one of those dollars is
going this is what you have coming in
the next week let's map out where every
one of those dollars is going let's map
out you should have enough with the
numbers you gave me
we should yeah we should didn't but
you're not doing that
right there it is okay
so you need you need to sit down and you
can jump on every dollar but the number
one the first thing is the two of you
have to do this together not turn it
over to him because
he because he can do it and you can't do
it that's not true okay and both of you
together need to do this because what's
going to have to happen is you're gonna
have to decide not to do a bunch of
stuff you're doing now that does that
doesn't matter as much as getting in
control matters
right I want to get in control more than
I want to go out to eat I want to get in
I want to get out of debt and have a
life more than I want to go on vacation
uh I want to get in control more than I
like this travel trailer I want to get
in control more than and I'm sick and
tired of living stress to stress to
stress to stress to stress with no hope
feeling like a rat in a freaking wheel
and when the both of you when both of
you are saying that and then you put
numbers to that and you say okay this
week on Friday we get a check for X the
following Thursday we get a check for
why the following Saturday we get a
check for Z and you write that down and
you plan out every one of those dollars
and where every one of them are going
because the water bill is due on the
second week the house payment's due on
the first week the uh student loan
payments due in the third week and we're
going to figure out what's coming out
we're going to take this much for food
this much for food this much for food in
the four different weeks and we're gonna
allocate every one of those bills to a
certain week and some of them across
weeks so that we have enough money to
take care of them and every dollar has
an assignment on paper on purpose before
the month begins we agree on it and spit
shake and pinky swear and then we don't
do anything else with money except what
we freaking wrote down
right and it seems like we've been doing
that for the last two months but we
can't catch that occur we can't get out
of here so you write it all down and you
don't have enough
no we do have enough but it seems like
it's gone every single week now if you
wrote it down to have enough
and then you did something else other
than what you wrote down
well I guess we're struggling is just
like every time we do try to we take we
get our bill every single you know
whatever a month we pay it once a week
and but we have so many little ones it
seems like we just don't know where
they're not all written down prioritize
them yeah we need to prioritize them
better every one of them
on paper on purpose in a certain week
this is a week one bill this is a week
four bill this is a week two bill
different bills have different weeks and
they all go within the income of that
week and then when the check comes in
the check is already spent so you can't
do anything except what you wrote down
you are not managing to the budget
you're writing it out as a hypothetical
and then going doing what you used to do
right and you're not focusing on get
ahead but listen Jim I'll tell you how
you've got it that'll get you ahead
that's what I told you yeah if you you
won't write down not getting ahead
you'll get ahead as soon as you do that
you've got room in this budget
yeah you're disorganized and chaotic
yeah
and when you give every single if I paid
you a hundred thousand dollars a year to
pay these bills exactly on time and you
had no emotional tied to them whatsoever
and you would look at this family that
this distant family over in Boise Idaho
and tell them to quit going to freaking
restaurants I don't care how tired you
are no whining aloud you're going to pay
the freaking bill on time if I told you
to do that you could do it for someone
else
right it's because it's not right it's
sixth grade math
you can do this so right you have got to
get very detailed very intentional and
then live the detail
don't write it all down and then go do
what you used to do and so well I just I
I didn't feel like cooking tonight I
don't give a crap go home and get some
leftovers out of the dad gum
refrigerator
that's how you do it you can't I mean we
all have that you just got to talk to
your whiny self and say no whiny self
I've done that myself I mean Sharon I've
done it to each other we know what it
feels like but you have to go I want
control more than I feel tired tonight
you know and that's the biggest thing
that's the phrase that comes out of
everybody's mouth by the way before they
go out to eat or before they hit the
fast food and get dog food at Taco Bell
you know or whatever and so it's just
it's horrible it's horrible value it's
horrible nutrition and it's out of
control spending
and so it's just yeah see you gotta
write it down and get on every dollar
download the app and I tell you what
I'll give you the upgrade I'll give you
the premium every dollar where it ties
to your bank
and we'll get you started on that Janet
because what you all desperately need is
a detailed budget and here's how you do
a budget folks you give every single
penny a name
every bill has a week allocated in every
dollar it's called paycheck planning and
you plan out each paycheck for the month
and you and your spouse both look at it
every dollar is assigned to saving to
giving or to a bill
period
every single dollar there is no missile
there is no uh well fifty percent of my
budget is not allocated bull crap
allocate every dime
in every dollar on the paycheck planning
every dollar has a name before the month
begins August is coming where's your
August money going to be it's going to
freaking disappear if you don't tell it
what to do it will leave and go to
people's houses who tell it what to do
and then you'll say stuff like the poor
get poorer and the rich get richer yes
they do because the rich tell their
money what to do yeah that's how this
works and so you got to get on top of
this stuff and lean into it every dollar
has an assignment you stick to it you
agree on it with your spouse and you do
not spend a dime unless it's on that
page on that every dollar app if it's
not on there and it comes up and it's a
surprise and you forgot it you got to
take something else off because if you
put something on there and you're
already spent it all now you're in
overdraft and now it doesn't work and I
can't seem to get caught up well you're
not getting caught it because you're not
living your plan do the plan live the
plan write the plan live the plan do the
plan live the plan live the plan and
it's your plan by the way you decide
where it's going to go but I'm telling
you what I'm doing I'm not going out to
eat I'm not going on vacation I'm
selling a stupid travel trailer
everything else is for sale so much the
kids think they're next we're going to
take extra jobs and we're getting
control because I'm tired of being
stressed out that's what I'm doing if
I'm in your shoes and I did it by the
way